Hé bien bonjour bonne année même si ça fait déjà plusieurs jours que c'était la nouvelle année ! Les amis j'espère que vous allez bien ! Moi
ça *tousse*
J'allais y venir. Je suis extrêmement malade je vous avoue je voulais tourner sur Getting over it pour finir le jeu et je crois que la
maladie tombe au bon moment parce que j'aurai tout simplement fait une crise de nerfs ! Le 25 juin j'avais fait une vidéo qui parlait de
mes trois cents soixante derniers jours sur YouTube et en fait aujourd'hui j'ai envie de refaire la même chose déjà parce que je crois que
suis dans l'incapacité de faire autre chose et ensuite parce que moment où j'ai fait cette vidéo là je pouvais pas me douter que ce
qui allait suivre allait être encore plus dingue ! Ces six derniers mois sur YouTube ont été
incroyables que ce soit en terme de rencontres ou en terme d'épanouissement
personnel ! Le 1er juillet je sortais sur ma chaîne le clip "Placements de produits" avec
Maxenss qui est vraiment devenu un très très bon ami ! En fait j'ai acquis énormément d'expérience quand j'ai bossé sur la vidéo "Overwatch rap battle", que
ce soit avec Pivi Nova ou avec Jules Fou ou avec Node d'ailleurs c'est la vidéo la plus vue de 2017 en France donc merci beaucoup !
Et ça fait plaisir à toutes les personnes qui ont bossé sur le projet donc
voilà merci. Après ça j'avais acquis l'expérience nécessaire pour faire une musique moi même mais je voulais pas faire ça seul je voulais que ce soit
un délire de potes, donc j'avais contacté Maxenss qui était hyper chaud par le thème et par l'ambiance aussi du
morceau et puis on a fait ça et c'était génial ! Deux semaines après je contacte Big Flo et Oli qui voulait trop qu'on fasse un
truc ensemble à l'occasion de la sortie de leur album pour leur annoncer une idée que j'ai eue qui serait juste de sélectionner des mots
au hasard dans un dictionnaire et de devoir les caler dans des couplets de rap.
Il faut savoir que c'est des mecs qui connaissent très très bien le YouTube game et qui sont très très gentils et ils voulaient déjà faire un
petit truc avec moi en 2015 donc je les avais invités à la fin d'une vidéo pour faire un pareil un petit chant un petit truc.
"Et voilà les gens c'est déjà la fin de cette vidéo j'espère que ça vous a plu ! Et si c'est-
Yo c'est Big Flo et Oli l'album et là on a visé haut on débarque chez Squeezie on fout le bordel dans ta vidéo
Comme Lucas on peut rater nos intros, faire le beau devant l'ordi, avoir la dalle comme Jumbo."
Je sais on était jeunes quand tu regardes ça maintenant t'es pas très bien tu es plutôt gêné on va pas se mentir mais en
tout cas c'était une trop bonne rencontre on avait kiffé et on s'était dit à l'époque que
à la sortie de leur prochain album on ferait un vrai truc cool chose faite on a sorti cette vidéo là dans laquelle on a déliré
sur le bandeau Alain Rey du dictionnaire et elle a hyper bien marché, le concept vous a trop plu la suite vous la connaissez
deux mois après je le redis les mecs ce qu'on a fait il y a deux mois c'était génial j'ai trop envie qu'on fasse la même
en mieux en fait en parallèle j'avais déjà contacté le petit robert, éditeur du dictionnaire qu'on avait utilisé dans la première vidéo et je leur
avais demandé si c'était possible d'avoir à Alain Rey et je crois qu'il était en vacances en Bretagne à ce moment là donc je n'avais pas
trop encore eu de réponse et en fait Bigflo et Oli ont eu la même idée que moi de ramener Alain Rey et m'avaient
demandé mec tu penses pas que peut nous ramener Alain Rey
j'avais tout donné pour pas qu'ils grillent, je leur avait même fait croire que Alain Rey avait trop mal prit le fait qu'on se moque du
bandeau et tout et qu'on utilise sa tête alors qu'en fait c'est faux, j'ai eu une réponse sept jours plus tard environ de l'éditeur qui m'a
dit bon bah Alain il est hyper partant il a adoré votre vidéo il a adoré ce que vous avez fait il trouve ça génial
comme principe et ensuite je représente ce fameux Alain Rey ils étaient
bah voilà vous l'avez vu dans le best-of il ya quelques jours il était vraiment sur le cul, ils étaient trop contents et Alain Rey
il est vraiment excellent il est hyper compréhensif attentif
rigolo et c'est un grand monsieur quoi franchement c'était un peu comme c'était notre grand-père à nous trois qui étaient venu et on avait
une sorte de respect naturel pour lui et il a un charisme
enfin c'était vraiment génial plus le lendemain soir on sort le clip qu'on a vraiment fait en une heure à
l'arrache, on faisait que trois prises par plan séquence fin bref et ben les gens ont vraiment aimé le truc quoi et aujourd'hui c'est pareil l'une
des vidéos les plus vues de ma chaîne 19 millions de vues je crois que c'est la deuxième vidéo la plus vue de ma chaîne
après Overwatch donc c'est ouf !
ces six derniers mois sur youtube sont aussi ceux où j'ai fait le plus de vidéos avec d'autres personnes que ce soit avec McFly
et Carlito, Natoo, Maxenss
Cyprien... j'ai vraiment fais énormément de vidéos à plusieurs parce qu'en fait je me suis rappelé que quand j'avais commencé youtube à l'époque en
2011 c'était dans cette ambiance là j'ai essayé de faire des trucs avec mes potes du lycée
de les ramener dans les vidéos
qu'on délire ensemble et en fait j'avais perdu le truc là pendant deux ans et en fait je m'étais isolé je bossais comme un chien je
faisais quatre vidéos par semaine et en fait
j'avais complètement oublié le pourquoi du je suis sur youtube pourquoi je me suis mis à faire ça et du coup ces six derniers mois
en fait ça a été une vraiment une libération ça m'a fait énormément
de bien de faire des vidéos avec plein de gens, la meilleure chose c'est d'inviter des potes en vidéo de
délirer avec eux parce qu'il y'a une complicité il y'a un truc et les gens adorent
ça en fait voir des gens qui s'aiment bien s'amuser entre eux se vanner et tout et même moi j'ai pris un plaisir
monstrueux à faire plein de vidéos avec McFly et Carlito c'était vraiment ma rencontre de 2017, c'est deux personnes formidables je les adore, ils m'ont
beaucoup apporté et c'est un peu mes grands frères
et je sais pas c'est une sorte de déclic bizarre que j'ai eu, en fait souvent on
se prive de certaines choses parce qu'on a peur parce qu'on n'ose pas parce qu'on est vraiment dans notre zone de confort mais je pense
qu'à un moment il faut aussi se faire kiffer, il faut oser faire ce qu'on a vraiment envie de faire au fond de nous
et puis les réactions, bah tu vois après et
il faut pas trop que ça te tracasse quoi, donc en parallèle de ce délire là de faire des vidéos avec plein de gens
je me suis aussi cette année ça c'est vraiment l'un des plus gros truc qui s'est passé toutes ces dernières années pour moi sur youtube
s'est arrêté de faire x nombre de vidéos par semaine de me forcer à les faire et je pense que la plupart des youtubeurs qui
font beaucoup de vidéos par semaine ont le même problème en fait, juste ils osent
diminué ça peut être vraiment très dangereux de continuer dans cette voie là perso j'ai fait ça pendant deux ou trois ans et en fait
déjà ça t'isole vachement parce que tu es devant ton ordi toute la journée à
trouver qu'est ce que tu vas faire le faire et ensuite le monter le mettre en ligne et ça 4x par semaine
alors il ya pire dans la vie je suis d'accord mais je pense que quand on est youtubeur il y'a tout pour être heureux
et c'est trop bête de gâcher le
la joie en s'imposant des trucs comme ça que personne nous impose en plus c'est complètement débile, du coup sur le tournage
je m'éclate plus, j'ai plus envie de le faire mais aussi au montage il se passe un truc c'est que du coup il ya moins
de vidéos à monter donc quand t'en montes une t'as plus de temps et surtout t'es plus épanoui dans ta vie parce que tu bosses
un peu moins donc tu te lâches un peu plus au montage. Je sais pas si vous saviez mais c'est pas moi qui monte mes vidéos
fin j'en monte certaines mais pas toutes du tout, la plupart des vidéos sont montées par Clément, Clément qui est mon monteur depuis maintenant deux
ans. En fait y'a un vrai travail de création derrière faut vraiment ajouter sa touch au montage sinon la vidéo est pas dingue. Clément se donne de
ouf il craque complètement son slip et euh... putain les vidéos sont géniales !
Clément
si tu regardes cette vidéo et vu que c'est toi qui vas la monter celle-là
je sais que tu la regardes est bien plein de gros bisous à toi et gros love et en parlant de Clément j'étais très content
parce que en août je suis allé au canada pour une opé par l'office du tourisme canadien
destination canada nul à chier cet accent, ça m'a fait trop du bien pour plusieurs raisons la première
c'est que je suis parti avec clément et en fait on n'avait jamais passé beaucoup de temps ensemble en fait moi je suis très casanier
très solitaire et Clément il est un peu pareil donc du coup on est jamais hyper ensemble à se voir tous les soirs et
tout et ce truc là ça nous a fait vivre ensemble pendant
sept jours mais de manière intense on a fait des activités trop cool ensemble même si on bossait on
s'était quand même hyper épanouissant et ça nous a vachement rapproché donc je trouve que c'était vraiment une bonne chose
ensuite au delà de ça j'ai pu rencontrer mes fans
du Canada
qu'on voit très peu en France parce qu'ils sont au Canada et il y'a cette fameuse scène dans je crois le deuxième vlog où je
vais une fête foraine dans une ville minuscule
du Québec vraiment toute petite et il y a plein de gens qui me reconnaissent ils étaient tous trop sympa, trop étonnés de me voir là
j'étais aussi étonné de voir autant de fans québécois je garde vraiment un
super souvenir de cette soirée à part les putains de piqûres de moustiques qu'on s'est mangé avec Clément dans la grande roue là, à la fin
horrible mec, il y avait mille moustiques à tous les étages de la roue c'était horrible
en tout cas les québécois vous m'avez fait vraiment chaud au coeur j'ai découvert un peu vos traditions, vos plats préférés
votre manière de vivre, votre joie de vivre vraiment merci à tous ceux que j'ai croisés là bas que ce soit des abonnés ou des
gens qui nous ont aidé au long de notre voyage c'était c'était fou et voilà j'en ai gardé un souvenir à jamais sur ma peau
par David Côté qui m'a tatoué et qui a aussi tatoué Clément d'ailleurs, tous les voyages que j'ai pu faire m'ont vraiment marqué et je me
souviendrai toute ma vie et le dernier que j'ai fais était
génial parce que c'était le Japon qui est mon pays préféré sur Terre et que j'ai pu adopter
enfin un
petit Shiba Inu c'est un truc que je rêvais de faire depuis plusieurs années mais comme je vous ai dit j'ai vraiment passé deux
ans la tête dans le travail à tourner et monter
tout le temps 4x par semaine j'avais vraiment aucun temps même pour m'occuper de Jumbo j'avais peu de temps c'était l'enfer du coup j'avais reporté
ce projet d'adopter un chien parce que j'étais tout simplement pas prêt et c'est une décision qu'il faut prendre au sérieux et pas du tout
à la légère. Je vais au Japon une première fois je le vois tout petit il était hyper content de me voir alors qu'il me
connaissait même pas je comprends toujours pas, moi je vois un inconnu arriver mec je m'en bats les c*******
lui me fait une fête de fou, je le sort il court il vient dans mes bras c'était dingue
je suis hyper gaga et des fois j'ai peur je me dis, attends peut-être j'en fais trop avec mon chien et tout mais vous savez
ce que c'est quand on aime quelqu'un ou un animal eh ben on a envie de
le montrer quoi et pas de se cacher. En expérience humaine on est aussi allé dormir dans une forêt avec Mamytwink dans la nature
on avait eu cette idée là plusieurs mois avant qu'on ait visité l'hôpital
abandonné et on c'était dit, mec ça serait trop marrant de faire une nuit en forêt on va vraiment chier dessus et tout, alors au final
s'est pas du tout chier dessus parce qu'il y avait François qui est tout simplement un vétéran
extrêmement fort avec nous. François y'a un ours qui vient il s'en bat les c*******, il fait une clé de bras à l'ours
il y a plus aucun problème, François tu es mon héros *rire*
c'est marrant parce que je regardais les émissions de Mamytwink il y a des années, il faisait des émissions sur
jeuxvideo.com et parlait de World Of Warcraft et me dire que quelques années après je me retrouve avec ce mec en forêt en train de
faire un feu et de fabriquer un abri, je trouve ça génial, Mamytwink, gros bisous à toi.
Novembre je sors mon
premier livre "Tourne la page" fait avec maxenss et mon frère, ça fait toujours plaisir de sortir quelque chose où tu sais que des gens
vont être contents d'acheter ce truc là parce qu'il est relié à toi c'est toi qui l'a créé et ils ont l'impression d'avoir un petit
truc de toi chez eux en fait et je voulais pas qu'ils aient cette
impression avec un objet nul à chier que j'ai même pas fais moi même là c'est vraiment un livre qu'on a fait nous mêmes alors
on l'aime ou on l'aime pas
c'est normal ça peut pas plaire à tout le monde mais au moins moi j'en suis fier et il y a rien de mieux que
d'être content de ce que tu as créé et de rendre des gens heureux
avec ça quoi voilà c'est ces derniers mois je suis aussi passé à la télé *tourne la page
vous aviez peur que vos fans soient incapables de savoir comment ça fonctionne, alors c'est devenu un métier donc en 2017 de regarder des
...gagner de l'argent
on en a vu des branleurs dans l'émission mais celui-là il est magnifique* putain de merde ça fait si mal encore même des mois après, c'est faux je peux pas faire cette
vidéo sans parler de ça
même si j'aurais aimé ne pas en parler parce que ça vaut pas le coup, pour faire la promo de mon livre
il fallait que je fasse une télé en gros et du coup on avait choisi Ardisson ce truc-là du mais vous êtes payés pour jouer
à des jeux vidéo ça avait déjà été exploité par je sais plus, Canal+ avec deux cônes je crois un ou deux ans avant
et ça avait déjà fait un gros bad buzz
en fait pour être franc avec vous moi sur le coup je l'ai pas mal vécu parce que c'est la télé vous savez très bien
comment c'est quand un youtubeur passe la télé c'est toujours comme ça que ça se passe
en fait cette affaire avec Ardisson c'est assez rigolo parce que les gens ont énormément réagi mais je trouve qu'en réagissant de manière
énervé comme ça en fait ils ont un peu gagné tu vois à la télé ils sont dit ha bah ouais ben c'est bien ce
qu'on pense c'est bel et bien une petite niche de gamins et dès qu'on critique un peu ils partent en furie comme des enfants de
12 ans je pense la meilleure chose à faire en fait ça aurait été de montrer à Ardisson qu'en voulant faire du buzz en clashant
bah ça marche pas malheureusement il s'est passé tout l'inverse a vraiment bien marché tout le monde en a parlé donc il a complètement
gagné en fait il a réussi à faire ce qu'il voulait faire c'est à dire faire un petit buzz grâce à un invité ben même si
ce n'était pas un très bon moment
on va pas se mytho je m'en fous, les gens ils savent ce que je vaux, je sais ce que je vaux
c'est pour ça en fait que sur le plateau j'ai pas du tout mal pris tout ce qu'il m'a dit est en tout cas je
vous remercie pour vos nombreux messages de soutien de courage ça m'a vraiment fait chaud au coeur même si j'allais pas mal je m'en foutais
complètement en fait de l'après cette émission et je trouvais ça trop mignon que tout le monde m'envoie des messages mais d'un autre côté je me
disais mais merde les gens ils pensent que je vais pas bien du tout alors qu'au contraire en fait je m'en fous complètement en fait
de ce qu'il s'est passé sur ce truc de télé moi mon truc c'est net et s'il se passait un truc comme ça sur ma
chaîne youtube là ça me fait vraiment chier mais à la télé je m'en fous
d'ailleurs certains ont cru que ma vidéo free style de l'auto dérision c'est en réponse à Ardisson mais pas du tout hein c'était prévu écrit bien
avant que je tourne chez Ardisson, toute la vidéo entière n'était pas basée sur le fait que je m'étais fait vanné chez Ardisson.
Enfin, bon les amis voilà, c'était ces 6 derniers mois sur Youtube, c'était intense, c'était fou. Il y a eu du gros changement dans ma vie.
Juste merci parce que j'ai le meilleur putain de métier du monde.
Et pour moi le plus important en fait c'est de rester sincère avec
vous et avec moi même, et de ne pas
m'enfermer dans un truc, de pas me mentir à moi-même, de pas me forcer à faire un truc alors que j'ai pas trop envie de
le faire mais j'ai peur des réactions des gens donc je le fais. Ces 6 derniers mois ont fait que j'ai aujourd'hui je me sens
vraiment libéré je me sens vraiment bien
j'ai beaucoup plus de temps pour moi pour mon chien et mes amis, ma famille. J'espère que les vidéos en 2018 seront encore meilleures qu'il y
aura encore plus de projets fous, que ça vous plaira encore plus et que de votre côté ce sera pareil que vos projets vont se
réaliser vous allez tout donner pour et puis je vous souhaite que du bonheur plein de bonnes choses ça fait trop du bien de faire
cette petite vidéo et vous parler j'en avais vraiment besoin je suis pas un modèle mais en tout cas je vous llivre juste mon avis
sur ces 6 derniers mois sur mon ressenti perso vis à vis de youtube, vis à vis de vous et voilà je vous dis à bientôt pour une
prochaine vidéo, bonne année encore une fois plein de bonnes choses plein de bisous à vous à vos proches et à tout le
monde moi je vais me foutre sous ma couette pour me remettre un peu de
cette maladie, encore merci à bientôt pour d'autres vidéos plus folles, ah j'ai des courbatures mon gars, j'ai l'impression d'avoir 80 piges